Will Ferrell might be one of the
funniest people on the planet but even
though he makes people laugh for a
living he's not immune to the power of
his own jokes especially when he and his
co-stars are improvising gags on the fly
so what makes the funniest star in
Hollywood laughs here's a look at some
Will Ferrell bloopers that make us love
him even more a glass case of screw-up
one of the most quoted lines in the
classic hit comedy anchorman is the
moment when during a breakdown in a
phone booth he shouts
but as this clip shows it took him a
while to get there and the mistakes were
almost as funny as the final take do do
it again the other bloopers how hard
must it be to film a scene with Ferrell
when he's in the middle of one of his
stream-of-consciousness
improv moments in the other guys
dramatic actors Ava Mendez found out the
hard way just how difficult comedy could
be when you're playing the straight man
to one of the funniest guys in Hollywood
the doctor said it was similar to
operating on a German Shepherd when they
have hip dysplasia it's just science
part of anchorman director Adam McKay's
job is to keep the jokes flowing so when
the Improv slows down he pitches in with
ideas to get his stars riffing which
backfired spectacularly on the set of
anchorman 2 when he suggested a very
unusual material could be used for the
filler and breast implants what else did
I hear this is I've learned
[Music]
and they just could not pull it together
the price the problems they're running
into is that now whenever a woman runs
this outtake is so hot right now before
his breakout role an old schoolmate of a
Hollywood star well Farrow spent his
time as a supporting actor stealing
scenes in other people's films like when
he played Mugatu in Zoolander luckily he
soon got his own movies no doubt thanks
to moments like this one Hey tantrums
sometimes work something extra it's hard
enough for superstar actors to keep a
straight face while working with barrel
now imagine how hard it must be for
extras well you don't have to imagine as
this slip-up on the set of daddy's home
- had the whole room breaking character
props never gave me a phone
talladega lunch one of the best love
scenes in Talladega Nights is the
extended sequence where Ricky Bobby's
whole family gets together for dinner
but co-star john c reilly loved it just
a little too much as he couldn't quite
keep a straight face during filming i
sure as hell am chip chip
bloopers of glory the skating comedy
blades of glory is just a minor entry in
Farrell's catalogue of comedy classics
but it sure looks like the cast had a
good time filming it Farrell and co-star
Rob Corddry seemed to have a
particularly hard time keeping a
straight face together
you smell like urine I would fire you if
you weren't so goddamn beautiful out
there
behold the majestic wolf lamp
stepbrothers is the tail of enemies who
become family and then become friends
just like Fairless clearly good friends
with his frequent co-star john c reilly
their camaraderie is on full display in
this ridiculous scene involving
Farrell's majestic wolf lamp
this is Galco which is Hebrew for
kindness
Jellico and it just kept going you can't
put a name on the innocence of that face
live from New York when you crack up
filming a movie you can just film it
again to get it right but when you crack
up on live TV there's not much you can
do except go with it as Ferrell found
out after having to introduce Tim
Meadows as dr. poop
[Applause]
we misplace to baby and that's not the
only time Farrell cracked during his
time on Saturday Night Live we're going
to the dolce gabbana show how fast did
you have your bags back from there I
keep on laughing well thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all the school stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you